[Music]
just look yeah really did what were you
doing I don't know I mess around and
then things happening yeah you feel bad
yeah you'll feel better soon all right
put on your laugh hat all right here we
go
American Horror Story hotel that's a big
show right now I was watching American
Horror Story hotel I didn't know what
was going on and then I hit the info
button and it said this season
characters attempt to survive a night at
a Best Western man I've had that happen
to me every time I go to bed all right
here we go Monaco Quantico I was
watching this show Quantico and then I
hit the info button and it said at
Quantico FBI stands for foxy babe
investigation that's what they wear at
Yakko camisoles that's standard-issue
camisole yeah Dance Moms I was watching
the show Dance Moms yep
there's Dance Moms I hit the button said
the show that will make you hate Dance
that's crazy
Dateline I was watching Dateline and
then I hit the info button and it said
see how the killer was caught and
learned from his mistakes Dateline now i
murder real good Chicago Fire I was
watching Chicago Fire yep
then I hit the button and it said it's
regular fire put with extra cheese
Supergirl
I was watching Supergirl yeah loved
Supergirl then I hit the info button and
it said like Superman but paid 30% less
don't blame us blame the government here
The Walking Dead let me hit the info
button said kids if you want a job after
college go into zombie makeup growth
industry blind spot I was watching the
show blind spot yeah pretty fascinating
then I hit the info button said on her
left leg they should have tattoo a more
believable storyline I still don't
understand I don't know dr. oz yeah then
I hit the info I'm gonna hit the info
button it said this wasn't what your mom
meant when she said go to Harvard had
become a doctor and finally a Hollywood
game night I was watching Hollywood game
night yeah and I hit the info button and
it said have you ever googled Michael
Chiklis Plus charades your search is
over hey thanks for watching be sure to
click subscribe to see even more great
Conan clips you may now return to your
pirated movies and creepy Japanese
pornography